joined now by the former head of the
British army that's General Lord done it
of course hello my Lord thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
I'm guessing you would concur with what
we've just heard there from Alex about
the Dynamics changing uh when winter
comes
uh yes that's absolutely right
um there is a certain amount of
understandable romantic action going on
at the present moment to try and get
into good position before winter changes
the dynamic changes the mobility
factions or characteristics of of the
battlefield but I think as you're
covering more generally The Wider issues
are the ones probably of gracious
concern at the present moment issues
such as a referenda going on in those
four four areas
um and also I think looking at it most
broadly the difficulties that Fusion is
coming under the adverse reaction to his
Mass conscription so there are many
areas to watch not just the battlefield
at the present moment
of course and I wanted to come on to
both of those points um if you'll
indulge me let's start with the
referenda first of all
um four areas that are being impacted by
this illegal under international law but
of course the annexation of Crimea was
also uh illegal how do you see that
referenda and its obvious outcome
panning out
well I think there are two obvious
points to make one is the Putin will
claim that the people in those four
areas have now spoken
um with their own voices and they want
to be part of the Russian Federation
people say that the West will completely
reject that we know because there's no
independent monitoring of the elections
that they are sham they are false they
are purely employed by him so I don't
think that will actually change anything
on the ground I think the concern is the
extent to which Putin might choose to
back up his rhetoric that in saying that
those four areas have chosen to join the
Russian Federation that they the
Russians will defend those areas with
all means possible and that brings back
the veiled or not surveilled threat of
of the use of nuclear weapons and that
obviously is concerning and always
through we've known there's a bit of
nuclear Shadow over this which puts him
from time to time refers back to trying
to put a threat of fear understand
accountability in the West
uh in my experience if a man says I'm
not bluffing he usually is what did you
think
well if it wasn't true they wouldn't
deny this I know exactly what you mean
Kate I think the thing is that the
Americans and NATO are quite wisely
saying or I suggest you can make your
Bluffs you can make your threats but we
have here the two not seen highly
sophisticated and highly capable
Conventional Weapons and if you use some
kind of nuclear weapon yes of course
we've got the option of responding with
a nuclear weapon but we have got
Conventional Weapons off huge power that
actually could be visited upon you
um if I was in one of the Black Sea
Fleet ships at the present moment I
wouldn't go to bed at night in my bunk
very calmly at night it's quite possible
because seeing that complete Fleet if we
chose to do so
oh um that's that's that's quite the
thought isn't it talk to me about the um
part mobilization that we're hearing
about we've also heard that conscription
officers uh have been uh targeted at
least 17 of them so far that we know
about according to Russian media so
maybe there are even more uh part
mobilization at the moment
um I'm guessing that could increase
further
well hitherto the war at home in Russia
has been somebody else's problem it's
been the problem of the of the regular
army if you like with those who have
been conscripted in the course of the
last 12 months and the normal course of
events now with his decision to go for
a partial mobilization although actually
it's rather more than that they are
pretty desperately trying to conscript
anybody that they can and the talk of
calling up reservist is pretty false
it's frankly just a an effort to harvest
as many men as they can and put them in
uniform that process has now made it not
somebody else's War it's made it
everyone's War and the Russian people
are not entirely but many many Russian
people are reacting adversely against it
I mean you've got to look at the
pictures of the cues for people trying
to get into Georgia not to not to
mention the attacks as you've just
suggested on many recruitment offices
this is deeply unpopular and the
unpopularity and the fact it's affecting
many people is now hitting home to
ordinary Russians so Putin has got an
increasing problem at home of his own
making
um did he have any alternatives actually
probably not because for the casualties
that they've taken killed and and
wounded he was running out of manpower
just as he's probably running out of
virtually everything else to do with his
military he's not going to give up he's
going to double down and this double
Downing is uh
the conscription uh and the under who
ring up for people to go into his
military is causing him an increasing
problem at home it may well be his uh
Julius Caesar moment
but also um you know I I did say you
know if a man says he's bluffing at not
bluffing he normally is but equally if
he is painted into a corner
we should be anxious about that
uh yes we should
um but there as I suggest there are many
dimensions to this it's not just
pressure he might think he's putting on
us it's real pressure on him and it's
also people in Russia uh looking at him
not just those who are against the war
there is an even more radical element
that actually is against Putin because I
think he's conducted the war so badly
there was an ultra nationalists who may
well decide the time has come for a
palace coup to get rid of him because he
has done so badly and frankly is an
embarrassment
um of course if that were to happen it
does beg the question if Putin was to go
who would follow and would that person
be any better
disappointingly the answer is probably
not
um it's always good to see you my Lord
thank you so much for taking the time
thanks Kay